A little while back, I was having a
conversation with another creator about
combo decks, and that conversation went
something like this.
I don't know that I'd consider combo an
archetype.
What would you consider it then? What
broader category does it belong to?
I don't know. Uh, finisher? A thing a
deck can do?
Hmm.
On a somewhat related note, last year on
a podcast, I was ranking archetypes in
Commander, and I said I don't think the
reanimator archetype is one that's
likely to feel good in Commander. Down
in the comments, there was a chorus of
people lightly pushing back, saying
something to the effect of, "But Snail,
graveyard decks are fun. I love my
Savin's Reclamation." This is
interesting to me because I don't
consider Savin's Wreck a reanimator
card. A nice little utility spell for
graveyard decks? Yes. A card played in
proper reanimator decks? No.
That phrase, proper, might begin to
elucidate the issue, though. I'm saying
a phrase, and it turns out that my
definition of that phrase differs from a
lot of other people's definition. Let's
go back to the combo example. What do I
think about the statement that combo
isn't an archetype, it's just a thing
that some decks do?
Well, in the context of Commander, it's
a pretty reasonable assertion. Combos
are a pretty common way of finishing off
opponents in mid- to high-power EDH
games, so trying to categorize them as
an archetype feels a little tricky. Is
every deck that wins with a combo
sometimes a combo deck? If not, where is
the line on what constitutes a combo
deck? What percentage of games need to
be won using a combo? What amount
dedicated to pulling off the combo? It's
a messy thing to try and properly
quantify. So, why do I and so many other
players think of combo as an archetype?
Put simply, it's because Commander
inherits a lot of cultural signifiers
from 60-card formats, and combo is more
of a well-defined archetype there.
In most 20-life 1v1 formats, combos
aren't actually the best way to close
out a game most of the time. This is
particularly true for ones that feature
higher-powered interaction, and we can
see this in the most popular win cons in
Legacy and Vintage. Vengevine, Glaring
Fleshraker, Psychic Frog, White Plume
Adventurer. These are simply extremely
efficient creatures rather than being
part of an A + B infinite combo. The
reason for this is simple. It's just not
necessary to use an infinite combo to
kill a single 20 health opponent on a
normal timeline. You'd be cracking eggs
with a sledgehammer. For this reason,
combo decks are generally a more
specific thing. Decks whose game plan
centers around executing a combo because
it offers some advantage in speed or
strengths in some specific matchups. Not
all decks that win with combos would be
widely considered combo decks. Some
might be a control deck that uses a
combo as a compact finisher. But, the
Venn diagram is close enough to a circle
that these things are often viewed as
one in the same. If you win with a
combo, you're probably playing a combo
deck and vice versa.
This, once again, contrasts with the
Commander format, where combos are
frequently the best way to close out
games in a wide variety of different
decks.
And, the more I thought about it, the
more I found myself agreeing with
Commander Bombs. Combo isn't really an
archetype. It's just a type of finisher.
A thing that some decks do.
This is paralleled when we think about
reanimator. The point of confusion
between myself and the YouTube
commenters was that when I think of
reanimator, I first and foremost think
of the archetype as seen in Modern or
Legacy.
This is a very specific type of deck
where the goal is to dump a horrifying
threat into the graveyard through an
Entomb or discard effect, and then use a
reanimation spell to bring it back out
into play as early as turn two. The
threats used for this are typically
either massive value sources like
Griselbrand or oppressive bombs like
Archon of Cruelty. And, the goal of the
deck is to capitalize on the massive
tempo swing of a big threat coming down
early in order to snowball into a win.
As I said in the podcast episode, I
don't think this strategy is a very good
idea to replicate in EDH. Trying to
snowball a turn two or three threat into
a win seems very likely to result in
simply getting pummeled by the table,
unless the threat is something so
disgustingly oppressive that it mostly
removes the ability of opponents to play
the game, ala Jin-Gitaxias or Void
Winnower.
A deck that has some strong follow-up
options might work, but the purest
versions of the play pattern are likely
to either result in pathetic failure or
a generational pub stomp. The vibes are
bad.
However, the commenters on that episode
weren't thinking of what I was thinking
of about reanimator. They were thinking
about the act of reanimation.
Actual reanimator decks don't really
exist in EDH due to the reasons I just
laid out. So, when EDH players hear the
reanimator archetype, they think about a
general graveyard deck that reanimates
things here or there.
In other words, reanimation as a thing
that some decks do.
And I can't even say they're wrong for
that, because in practice, that's
basically all reanimator is within the
EDH format. This pattern continues onto
other so-called archetypes. Take
control. I have an idea of what control
means to me, various other people have
an idea of what control means to them,
but when you get into the broader image
of it in the EDH community, it mostly
comes down to two things: counter spells
and board wipes. If a deck board wipes
every turn or two, or counters multiple
spells a turn cycle, that's a control
deck. Think Baral, Child of Alara, that
sort of thing. I also see this whenever
I do deck reviews. I start digging into
a deck that somebody has labeled a
control deck, and it's a massive pile of
removal and counter spells.
Now, unlike reanimator or combo, I do
think control decks meaningfully exist
in EDH, and they can actually look
relatively healthy within the broader
ecosystem. The most prominent feature of
a control deck to me is a multi-card
engine that repeats effects that
generate value or deal with opposing
permanents. Flickering is a common way
of facilitating this, as are graveyard
synergies that recycle already played
cards. This sort of engine then helps a
deck scale into the late game to the
point where it's nigh unstoppable. In
the context of this sort of deck,
removing opposing threats is important,
but so is not removing opposing
permanence. Picking out the threats that
can be left on board safely while the
control deck spends its resources
building value instead, while still
dealing with the ones that are more
immediately problematic. So, this is my
vision of control in EDH, and I think
it's one that has a highly dynamic play
pattern, both to pilot and to play
against. The problem is, it's about as
effective as a massive pile of board
wipes. Wiping the board in a four-player
free-for-all format is just a really,
really strong thing to do. And so, a lot
of players end up building these board
wipe tribal monstrosities that
constantly flush away all creatures or
even all non-land permanents, thereby
removing all the thinking of what
permanents can be allowed to stick
around for a bit.
Can I honestly say these aren't control
decks? No, I really can't. A dainty
little flicker Archaeomancer pile is
just as valid of a control deck in EDH
as a board wipe pile. That's just how
the format works. And board wipe pile
doesn't even really refer to a specific
set of goals or play patterns. It's just
a thing a deck can do, playing a board
wipe, cranked up to its limit and paired
with whatever else a player might feel
like doing that works in tandem with
that.
There are plenty more examples of this
to be found. Whereas 60-card aggro decks
have cutthroat optimized mana curves and
very distinct play patterns, aggro decks
in Commander are generally just midrange
decks that are stronger earlier in the
game, such as the challenge of playing
in a three-opponent 40-life format. Some
aggro decks can get around the
three-opponent issue by having most of
their damage be ping-style effects, or
get around the 40-life issue by using
commander damage or infect, but
basically none can dodge both of these
challenges. And as a result, all of
their speeds will be mediated by the
need to punch harder and stick around
longer.
We can also think about classic
archetypes that are borderline
disallowed at most tables: Ponza,
Prison, and Discard. In a cutthroat 1v1
format, these are fixtures. But in the
social format of EDH, they're endlessly
taboo. So, this is the general point I'm
trying to make here. The Commander
format does not have distinct archetypes
in the same way most other formats do.
And actually, the phrase archetype has
increasingly been phased out in the
Commander player lexicon in favor of a
different term, theme. I've kind of
noticed this in some ways, but it's
taken a handful of these run-ins with
so-called archetypes to really cement
things in my brain. In the year of our
Lord 2026, Commander decks don't fit
into dramatically different play styles,
but rather different flavors of
existence. They have things that they do
rather than things that they are.
However, this observation demands a
couple follow-up questions. For one, did
Commander ever feature a lot of distinct
archetypes? Was it once wholly and pure,
only now marred by a decade and a half
of precon designs pushing decks in more
generic directions?
In my subjective experience, the answer
is yes, but that's only because most of
my pre-2023 Commander experience was
playing with a group of 10 budget decks
that me and my friends specifically
designed to fit into different
archetypes. Even there, the aggro,
control, and combo decks felt a little
mid-rangey compared to their 60-card
counterparts, but there was still a
distinctness that doesn't exist as much
in Commander or more broadly.
Personally, I miss that differentiation
a bit, but it's definitely a reflection
of a cool micro-format me and my friends
built more so than it is a reflection of
how Commander used to be.
At its inception in the '90s, EDH decks
were janky and disjointed to the max, a
collection of all the interesting and
wacky cards that didn't quite fit into
all of the 60-card decks of the day.
Anybody who's played in a chaos draft
can tell you, when When cohesion of a
card pool drops, the result is that deck
plans get simpler and more generic. To
be clear, this is a different style of
generic than modern Commander decks.
These days, decks tend to be stronger
overall, featuring both a bit more
cohesion and also a lot more card draw
and other vegetables to hold things
together.
It's still a form of continuity, though.
Commander decks have always been a bit
more generic and a bit less cohesive
than their 60-card counterparts. The
second question worth asking is, is this
fact good? Is the fact that Commander
differs from 60-card formats in not
having conventional archetypes a
problem?
For the most part, I would say no. It's
not a problem.
As I said, I enjoy when Commander decks
are a bit more distinct from one
another, when they fill different roles
and peak in power at different points in
the game. But, Commander decks looking a
lot like one another is very much
something to be expected. In a 100-card
singleton deck, there will be a natural
limit to how specific a deck's game plan
can be, and that will result in more
shared attributes between decks. In a
four-player 40-life format, everything
will be slower, and as a result, decks
will be expected to grind at least into
the mid-game.
This also means that almost all decks
will want card draw, ramp, and removal,
unlike in 60-card formats where some
decks are able to get away with little
to none in one or more of these
categories.
Precons have certainly prodded Commander
in a particular direction, but I don't
think that direction represents anything
aberrant or unexpected. Maybe if I grew
up playing the super-duper version of
Commander, I'd be resenting the gentle
power creep and gradual streamlining of
precons, but I didn't, so I don't.
The one part of this that is a little
less ideal is the fact that
non-Commander formats have become so
secondary within the game. It's
absolutely not a problem for a more
casual format with less clearly
differentiated decks to exist, but what
about when it's the default? I remember
back in the early to mid-2010s when
Commander lived alongside other formats.
Somebody who wanted to play Commander
with their friends could do so, since
most people had a Commander deck or two,
but they also wouldn't have too hard a
time finding somebody who wanted to play
Standard or Modern or Pauper or even
kitchen table 60-card magic. Contrast
that with now, where it feels like the
average Magic player is more likely to
have a fourth or fifth Commander deck
than they are to have a 60-card deck put
together and ready to play with. And
they also probably aren't all that
interested in playing in a draft. And
just to be clear, there are reasons that
Commander has succeeded to the extent it
has. Reasons that go beyond the outsized
level of support it gets by Wizards of
the Coast compared to other formats.
It's great as a casual social format.
It's just worth keeping in mind what we
might be missing out on.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
Archidekt actually has an advanced
search feature for the decks within it,
and this includes colors, Commander,
inclusion of a specific card, and deck
tags like themes or archetypes it fits.
Want to see what various people consider
to be a reanimator deck, or dive into
the various lists on Archidekt that
feature the card Wild Research? This is
your ticket.
I also want to thank Dragon Shield for
supporting the channel. If you want to
pick up some of the awesome new Guild
Duel Mats, while also supporting the
channel, you can follow the link in the
description and use code Salubrious at
checkout for 5% off. If you want to
support the channel more directly,
consider joining my Patreon or becoming
a YouTube member. I'm currently taking
submissions for my next deck review, and
if you want a shot at getting your deck
reviewed, becoming a supporter is your
way of doing that.